I'm here at the Berlin
Tempelhof Airport.
This is an iconic site,
one of the most famous
airports in the world.
It was the scene of the Berlin Airlift,
between 1948 and 1949,
Berlin was cut off from
the rest of the world,
and this city was fed by the West.
Planes landed here every 30 to 45 seconds
to bring valuable food, medical supplies,
and it helped save West Berlin.
Tempelhof is again playing a pivotal role,
because right now 1,500
refugees are living here,
refugees from Afghanistan,
Syria, Iraq, Iran,
so many hoping to either go
back one day to their own homes,
where it will be peaceful and safe,
or, possibly, to assimilate.
So, I want to go in,
I want to talk to them
and find out what's going on.
Hello, my name is Conan.
Where are you from?
Palestine.
You're from Syria.
What are you studying?
Could you see yourself
living here in Germany,
do you think?
I'm standing here with
gentlemen from Afghanistan.
How long have you been here, at Tempelhof?
And what do they do while
they're here at Tempelhof?
Could you ask them
if there is one message
they would like to get out to the world,
what would that be?
The good news is that most people,
in their hearts, understand that.
Is their hope to one day go home
to a peaceful Afghanistan?
It's interesting because
they're living in a city now,
Berlin, that was completely
destroyed by war,
and yet this city grew back
and is more vibrant,
stronger, more diverse, than ever,
and I think that would be
a bright message of hope
to people from Afghanistan.
So what's your favorite sport?
I'm an amazing dancer.
When I dance, all the
women fall in love with me.
Why is he laughing?
He doesn't believe me.
You don't believe me, do you?
(laughs)
See that?
Pretty good huh?
That's it, guys, let's try it.
Hey look at that, I like that!
Yes!
Important question:
Is everyone else jealous
of his amazing mustache?
You want that mustache?
You want that?
With the magic of television,
I can give you that mustache,
if you look right at
that camera right now.
See!
(bell rings)
Congratulations.
(upbeat pop music)
Aaagh!
Gah!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
You guys are mean!
Yay!